selbst ist willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute gehen sonst dezember in
diesem sinne frohe weihnachten
der heute nacht aber leute
selbstverständlich macht man natürlich
war da auch keine pausen heute 420
dezember im video raus und dafür haben
wir uns das folgende ausgedacht ihr
könnt ihr alle versuchen nicht zu lachen
videos und ihr kennt wahrscheinlich auch
versuchen nicht zu singen videos und wir
machen heute eine weiter entdecken davon
machen ein versuche keine emotionen zu
zeigen wie die und das bei einem thema
das man weiter jetzt sehr empfindlich
ist und sein besonders ist und zwar
schlechte geschenke wie sollte
unsympathisch die v-leute wäre das ganze
funktioniert wir werden vielleicht eine
geschenkte compilation anziehen und
werden dabei versuchen so nüchtern wie
möglichst ganz zu kommentieren keine
miene zu verziehen sobald eine
irgendeine emotion zeigt hat er verloren
der gegner punkte für das leben muss
einfach so leute die man schon was
machen aber jetzt weiß verschluss
emotionen raus zum wegschmeißen
das hat er bekommen
stoffen oder gelangt in dem haus gerannt
ich werde über den inhalt
wir hatten ist das aber das geht heute
würde nur das übervolle ist in der cd
version von dr warten
bei erfolg aus denn beim kinderlauf ist
wo ich würde direkt direkt jung verpackt
und weiteres kind hier
wir sollten das jetzt nicht wieder holz
haben oder so
der gast erst mal wieder seinen kopf
hängen lassen wieder weggesteckt hat
damit ist richtig aber ich habe nicht so
gesagt nur möglich ich habe keine
reaktion gezeigt
na ja so was von dir ausgeben und damit
sein
was steht da jetzt kein bleiben sehen
möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
und jetzt leute übergebe ich selbst für
eine kurze unterbrechung um meine
weihnachtsgeschenke zu finden sie hat
das video geht danach normal weiter
vielen dank sebastian danke fürs
weitergeben meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren oder das wollte ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht aber ich nehme
das jetzt gerade auch am 22 dezember das
heißt weihnachten steht direkt vor der
tür und ich denke jedes mal eigentlich
immer dass diese sache so ein bisschen
falsch aufgebaut ist weil eigentlich ist
weiter von zehn jahren zur ruhe kommen
sollte sich bisschen entspannen sollte
heißt nicht einfach so aus dass man die
üblichen geschenken hinterherrennt und
irgendwelche leben rennt und lässt mir
dennoch in welche geschenke besorgt und
eigentlich noch mehr gestresst ist und
dann von weihnachten erholung brauche
ich bedanke mich definitiv aber dann
leute hab ich was du bist ja irgend ein
netzwerk von der kampagne erfahren die
die sparkassen und peter direkt gerade
machen und zwar heißt diese kampagne
hashtag können den direkten dieser
kampagne direkt geht es um genau das
problem was gerade eben angesprochen
haben nämlich dass man in der
vorweihnachtszeit eigentlich gute
gestresst sind derzeit man eigentlich
entspannt sein sollte und zu leicht aus
dem jahr raus rufen sollte ist man am
meisten gestresst und dagegen wolf
sparkasse und per direct eben was machen
indem sie sagen geht du du und du ihr
müsst nicht die ganze zeit den
geschenken für euren täter laufen könnt
ihr euch selbst mal was von der
sparkassen wahrscheinlich alle von euch
mal gehört aber von direct vielleicht
nicht was per direct hey direkt aus
einem online bezahldienst der deutschen
banken und sparkassen und macht quasi
das man einfach über das internet sicher
bezahlen kann zwar nicht mit irgendeinem
anderen diensten wie sonst irgendwie
enthält herumschwirrt sondern wir im
dienste eben auch von der bank angeboten
wird bei der man zum beispiel auf sein
konto per direct kann man genauso wie
mit anderen anbietern für online
zahlungen auf den tausenden shops online
bezahlen der große vorteil von
pauldirekt ist dass dieser bezahldienst
eben von banken selbst angeboten wird
und dadurch eine ganz enge verknüpfung
zwischen dem p konto und dem eigenen
girokonto ist hier selbst schon aus
getestete und die anwendung
wir sind wirklich visite und habe mir
das hier besteht ein google hauptburg
hat jetzt weil die dusche gerne singen
wilde musik hören will und wenn ich
nachsehen hatte der deutsche kanzler
nicht bedienen deswegen braucht das und
musik du spielen zu können im badezimmer
aber kommen wir zum eigentlichen inhalt
leute wie gesagt die kampagne heißt
könnt ihr direkt und es geht darum sich
selbst was zu können wie gesagt kann mit
den unzähligen online shops bezahlt eine
davon ist raab mit kunden zusammen die
das angebot hingeblättert ihr bekommt
sollte damit ihr euch jetzt in der
weihnachtszeit vor weihnachten oder noch
ein paar tage nacht ist selbst was
gönnen könnt welche auch von guten
einkauft um mit der direkt bezahlt 10
euro rabatt auf 15 euro
mindestbestellwert nein
doch ganz einfach mit dem coldplay
direkt 2017 nicht optimal zwischen meine
füße hey direkt 2017 ist der code 10
euro rabatt beim einkauf selbst 15 euro
ist schon älter die leute ihr könnt bis
zum 27 dezember leute bis zum 27
dezember könnt ihr mit diesem code zehn
oder 15 jahre mindest bestellte können
ohne könnte sich zudem schon ziemlich
verraten aber es gibt leute und zwar
einen körper ultra die smart tvs von
samsung was ihr dafür machen müsst ist
einfach bis zum 27
dezember was bestellen sollte es bei
euch da heißt foto machen auf den posten
und dann einfach die schaufel an foto
hel stadtsparkasse hashtag play direkt
und hashtag können direkt einschreiben
dann entweder anteil hatten auch chancen
fernseher zu gewinnen natürlich darf mir
ist auch für euch auch ganz kurz vor
weihnachten gut zu wissen wo man sich
noch eine kleinigkeit gönnen will kann
man das dann machen wir noch und ich
geld aber spannend und jetzt lieber
sebastian zurück zu dir
deutschland könnte aber passieren dass
wir inflation eine originalverpackte
kurz nehmen ich nehme ihm den tipp sogar
aufgerissen das sind normale leute das
war jetzt nicht das ist nicht mal witzig
leute war das hat nicht dadurch haben
wir die kommentare ab etwas älteres kind
okay aber wurde sieht nachhall von
ausland durchaus wahr ist dass könne
gemeinsam auch es interessiert uns
hoffentlich auf der emotionalen mehrere
eingepackt das macht aus china sind eine
generell sind roma von service attacken
und überhaupt ein erstes gerät der firma
apple
aber es ist ein treff doch nichts drin
sondern auch ein kleines problem eine
ganze zigarette und darüber gespanntem
wird es ist eine hose die gastgeber
können
bei mir war das hat verläuft
was es geht wie soll wird seine ganze
selber wenn 2017 schon jetzt das meinen
der abend so schnell helfen
leute ich kenne hier zu lassen und zwar
macht ihr rasierschaum und gibt es im
letzten training werden die presse ist
das trinken ja was da drin
nehmen sie jetzt drin gehabt das
geschenk eingeschränkt und gut ist oder
nicht kann ich jetzt bleiben verurteilt
einfach so und ich habe bisher mit bis
zu zwei jahre alten dienste des
vereinsmeisters geworden ein spielstand
gesehen dass ich eigentlich glaube dem
spielstand ist gerecht geworden arbeit
text für diese mission mit dem
rasierschaum mit dem wassertiefe dazu
gekommen als ihr sehr sehr viel halt
nicht so weit wachsen und dann schon
folgt natürlich ja weihnachten das ist
froh sein business pack open